okay I am absolutely delighted to be
able to introduce our featured speaker
if you can imagine a professor's dream
come true then you are prepared for and
meet them and reap the ball and some
people came to Teachers College have
received her master's degree even as she
came from India with the master's degree
in clinical psychology and she took what
was the assignment I've been getting
students for about a decade and she
turned it into a vision and a project
and created the logo and Kaiba showed me
the logo we talked about how she met
someone who might not over funding
graduated and lo and behold created a
model demonstration product in India and
a female prison in the male prison it is
a model for all of us to consider in all
of our particular countries as matter of
fact one of the main reasons why one of
the Minister of Health with honor to be
here is because I was hoping that he
would see the promise of doing this
model in all the prisons in God so it's
right that were videotaping this so I
will direct to the Minister of Health
that this is the vision this is what is
possible in God and for those of you who
are working in other countries around
the globe this is what's possible all
those places too so he's going to show
you the final product and we're going to
it my talk which will be a rather short
I'll talk about how we're also making
this information of for other models of
your education globally available
without further ado I introduce to you
dream come true the one with passion and
commitment and vision and the
willingness to work hard and Rita ball
thank you very much for doing
introduction professor Wallace thank you
so much it's in fact a huge honor for me
to be able to share my work with you
here today and thank you so much for
allowing me to do that I am going to
begin by telling your story and this
story of passion and commitment involves
to media so bear with me if I'm fumbling
with my technology here i'm going to be
showing you a film and i'm going to be
using my powerpoint slides as well okay
so before you begin to tell you this
story i want to give you a brief
background it's going to sound like a
history lesson but it isn't i hope it
wasn't serious this is a story but
attitudes how we changed attitudes in
india and what I would like you to do is
travel back with me in time to ancient
India the land of mysticism snake
charmers and Yogi's it's about fourth
century AD between fourth and fifth
century and the great learn it a
philosopher but serena has just finished
riding the Kama Sutra have you all heard
about the Kama Sutra oh yeah I gotta
know I right here but for those of you
who have not heard about it it is this
ancient indian texts on love sex last of
course and also human sexual behavior
and boxer jana did not have to deal with
censorship back then so you know he
pulled all the songs he wrote such
graphic details about how you can
pleasure yourself and how your body can
be like a house of pleasure ok now let's
fast forward and warp speed to the year
two thousand five overa lot of time to
share everything with you so reporting
and so we gone over some 2,000 years
already okay during this time india has
been invaded by different nations Indian
culture has been influenced by their
culture so what you see is modern-day
India growing superpower as we would
like to believe with a booming economy
that with one problem we don't talk
about sex the land that gave you
kamasutra does not want to talk about
sex it's taboo we just don't mention it
and what's happened as a result of this
we have two point four seven million
people who are HIV positive and one of
the primary routes of transmission is
sense it's through the sexual round so
you know this is a problem and because
of his lack of communities being fueled
by this lack of communication that we
have okay sorry okay so before I get to
this slide actually let me tell you that
when I went back in 2005 this was the
environment that I was working in I had
to deal with people with bureaucrats who
did not want to talk about HIV as openly
as I would like to talk about it you
know when I talked about masturbation I
was looked upon and I'm a girl and as a
girl it was as a woman it was more
difficult for me to go and talk to men
about it so anyhow we went ahead with
like professor Wallace told you are
designed this pure led health education
program and I went back to India to
implement it and we talked this the
focus of this program was hiv/aids
prevention but is it it was disguised on
the under this garb of a overall pure
health education program oh because I
did not want to face too much opposition
to talk about it and also because there
are other disease diseases that we need
to talk about for example TB is super
closest is endemic in our country we
need to talk about these issues so it
was then that we started say Hut and we
talked about different modules we even
talked about life skills training etc
people ask me why did I choose prisons
an option well first of all they are one
of the most neglected and marginalized
people and it extremely vulnerable why
because we have severe overcrowding in
our prisons if you look at figures for
example let me talk to you about stay
hard preserves it is the pilot site for
our program it is built to house only
5,000 prisoners it's currently housing
thirteen thousand prisoners so you can
imagine the proximal distances that they
the lack of it in our prison and also
because I want to talk about your the
prison is a place where the three
high-risk populations are going to be
present at some point these are the
female sex workers which is by the way
sex work is illegal in India as is drug
use and you know long-distance truck
drivers are not immune to committing
crimes so at some point you know these
three high-risk populations are rotating
in our prison and I wanted to be able to
reach out to them as well and also
because of you know we have so many
people who of a waiting child the Indian
judicial system is very faulty you know
people have to languish in our jails for
nearly five six years before they get
the first hearing so here are people who
are waiting for their tone and you know
we can teach them things different
things and we can train them for you
know future employment one of my key
visions is to be you know is to create
this parallel health force which you
know community health workers who can
work in partnership with the government
so that is one of the key reasons why I
wanted to work in prisons I'm going to
share the film with you now and we just
take it from there then thank you
sadly it's happening don't know if lucky
that's just you know tech issues
ok
yeah i think we bought it it's loading
okay
this film was made by a gentleman caller
is benari bharucha he was you know it's
very difficult to get into our prisons
we have to take permission at the view
at the ministry level so it was tough
but we managed to get him on board to
come in and shoot a few sequences for
you all to see about what's happening in
one of the prisons in India the project
is being piloted at two sites one is a
tea hard and the other is amritsar
prison
oh how amazing to this the most happiest
day in my life maybe I'll do anything
I'll go online we taking your writing my
object equals up with a certificate will
I had always liked on something when I
appearances up a bit but Samantha boiler
it was very sad this product is I'm
gonna do it I'm a big girl peacekeepers
movement gonna say and say okay I'm
gonna be me take a little reversal okay
Francona put cika domain at me is
already made it's late Tommy Salman AC
cup o minutes they have mitigated are
missing Derek Manning about Indian
information says I'm researching of
energy from similar a geometer partial
of X equal a domani air I took up your
head Javon compressor thing or so much
liquid courage thing it's really doing
all right sides are illiterate or man
just articulate the very useful program
event for us and for the society of
remarrying about of Obadiah this week
after that with this output model over
in between our see how to drop out okay
now just because more than teaching the
modules the most important thing is to
relationships the full form is social
education health advocacy training and
it's an acronym say it is
they started in May thousand six in PR
and april 2006 in America we are any
division foundations and from Exeter we
were looking for funding and remember
the people is amazing but now we have
solution for your dollars in physical to
do not fight it and we have commissioned
for the number-6 it's the biggest reason
wallets and virtual reality he is very
handsome free oxygen oh yeah you wanna
come bohemian so not lucky that idea the
economy our was raised on rock desert as
that whether you are probably vomit at
over yet to save each other their yoga
para la gondola because HR he does not
have a pure head it is imperative that
we will we believe in prevention methods
we know that almost one-third into
prison population is coming on the
dishes crime and drug abuse crime and
alcoholism crying and promiscuity all
these are very very heavily pigmented
and SIV is a byproduct of all this
currently the population of prison areas
more and turning 23 other and therefore
it feel the need to go to different
prisons because of you know this is a
setting population we can optimally
train them this is the first experience
for me also interacting with NGOs and I
am very happy and satisfied to the wall
because there are lot of a Jews in
kale working at present but this is the
first angel who is involved America
stargaze room when I started my tear
proof they didn't know the performance
they have surveys will call the class
like a condom class HIV class pure-play
health education programs are very
important simply going to change is not
enough value and the pyramid a primal
source of information you would talk to
your friend and companion to any more
than it sounds five years older to do
with trying to do something right so
that is why I fell to me for a purely
program as well and the token of our key
infectious diseases even then I'm sorry
busca by venomous x karratha the account
numbers erosion told me some Duffy if
the one second is equivalent to a bath
the other four wanna go for another sash
for any other book HIV very same token
videos they are constantly unbelievable
because we leave a menace our belly they
were so visibly upon arrival at our
expense peer leaders I had inmates who
have never stomach for completely
integrated and they have been challenged
by this project that they've actually
gone on to know you need to read and
write Jane Eyre you can I have to say to
me I wouldn't walk to the Gaia Google to
find that DVD of HIV gotta go so many
perhaps Nibiru the Anunnaki limit also
scavenger walk idol what we did was they
be partnered one little person of
evolution personally with a less
literate person so Amina partnered up
with a girl go Sonja so he departed out
to the purple new girl it was a male
benefited by learning a few more things
at the same time they have a position of
responsibility we want is a program will
be a participation children there's a
collection because you know a body
principles of adult learning you cannot
just lecture people expect them to
retake so it's more important as far as
you play and do come on activity Susie
came up they have no charger I think
what is really work is the fact that we
had some finding books right number four
we use don't want to explain how
infections happen three basic Fernando
we have devised a game of flashcards
fast are very very uses to showing HIV
transmission how he said transition
occurs one of the methods we used
innovative games explain the human
communication it was such a challenge
that module is a huge challenge for us
rich ship in a similar be obtained a
sauce shop in Salem fight wrote a song
based on looks alone Gordon y'all I
guess it is a measurement Pollyanna
cuz they r it is naturally against all
of unity with a Jaffa Gate we organized
this programming cj5 no male prison in
theory and we have to shoot for
chauvinism big success this would be
that means hold please varmints updates
on topanga magic show now super got my
neck that but these are appealable you
to teach them I may take more interested
we have conducted a lot of
demonstrations also my doctors helped a
lot of classes and wherever they might
us we have a video tell them i think the
most important thing that we've achieved
so far and really it's taken up the
whole full one year 365 days to be this
turnaround in the prison authorities to
allow us to be fun in demonstrations so
ein week on the demonstrations mail and
feeling so that both people know how to
use to make a methodology we talked
about how the contraceptive this as well
apart the section 377 homosexuality
Lincoln so we really cannot distinguish
comments however a platform is the fact
that we are not talking to the
authorities and they say okay when
they're going to be released we get that
point you can handle funds
in the way personal thing back together
is very rampant for that was what we are
trying to do at this point of time is to
make sure that we tell the police this
symbol even if they do continue with it
we want to tell instrumental methodology
with existing resources the hospital's
oral sex they impose natives
masturbation it can engage on this is
neither think that we could not talk
about a year ago you know now my boy is
important we talk to me about it it
won't happen earlier you know these are
HIV something like two people have very
scared of it here and whenever become to
know that we are suffering from this is
it is a very emotional shock corded
telephone booth is immoral and neither
are they such a very said it will be
something Sita was a fastening the
garage alert there's a scheme to the
sooner you book it in overtime this is a
local opinion the 10 to the power J come
on your action even it out the
color undertake a junkie saga an
agreement of Oliver's any one of the
Heritage worship team Bobby Monte this
is gonna bug Olivia Tom get if
everything we released after Elena
I think what this program is done it is
not just taking them away from HIV
issues but insulting to them a sense of
responsible citizenship it's talked
about total it's sort of a good head
it's talking of personal restraint it's
not a responsible behavior or of my boys
Google to be have gone to the respective
little have done a sense check of what
we recover over there and have started
media with me now it's a portion is that
coo let me set up and they telling me
that they want to start failure indian
respectively they want to go to colleges
and schools better start okay so there
is no financial incentive in most of it
so that means we have achieved some
degree of success in their mama drama
bothers of the gowalla would i go to
over achieve a similar case tomorrow
Bellamy move the car collection vol one
of the policy you remember sorry
difficult mission i educate yourself
because to come and UT for my children I
will teach my friends all my family's
and we see them or whatever angle
and I think the success of sales project
of indie half a may act as an incentive
and mainly reports Indian art music stay
on with this project and take it a
little closer to local 16 because it's
replicated United Nations need to smoke
with more money and he didn't to stay
with the project develop training
material won't leave the trainer's
programs and then find the funds and he
should go to the capital cities if the
imagination were to withdraw funding at
this point we will have to greatly say
them my dogs will feel so bad baby feel
so helpless if we don't continue
y
you
thank you thank you we had some visitors
from India to just flew in last night I
would like you to meet chaudhary charan
singh chubby no mistake I rose up goal
namaste namaste namaste and his wife
sionary so there you know hater oh now I
say dr. Wallace hey dr. Wallace see dr.
Wallace you're so famous they already
know you in India ok so I'm going to
just give you up before I give you an
update on what's happening in India I'm
i just want to share with you that we
are one of the first NGOs to do a condom
demonstration in an Indian prison and we
are also one of the first NGOs to do a
voluntary HIV testing camp in the prison
of the 75 people that we tested only one
turned out to be positive so I'm not
sure you know I mean we don't want to
force anyone to come forward and test
and as you can see there was this one
boy one of my leaders he chose not to
get tested despite the counseling and we
did not want to force anyone so you know
that's just something that I want to
share with you ok so I'm going to give
you a quick up there and what's
happening and attach a ternary haha
without you without you ok she's just
telling me what the latest Oh since
she's just flown in last night she just
wants to let me know what's the latest
what's happening so here's some stuff
that we put together Thank You sionary
bought the car shook up colors ok so 15
peer leaders have been trained so far
under the program and these leaders have
gone on to extend their peer groups in
different wards the set up in the prison
is that each prison has different wards
and I was allowed access to only one
word as a pilot for the pilot so now my
the boys can go to different words and
that's what they're doing they're
educating people about what they've
learned and they're using the say hot
natick mandeley which means it's
the wrong munch or like a troupe of
puppeteers and actors so the traveling
within the within this prison and
spreading the word and I'm hoping that
you know they get to get permission to
travel to the different prisons within
the complex of this large the hard
prison ok and the pure leaders who've
been released in fact one of them who
was singing that guy his name is Sean
and we invited him to our annual Day
function and he sang in front of like
some 700 odd people it was such a
wonderful experience for him and you
know it's it's just amazing how he's
connected with us after that he's made
you know I think we got a lot of
credibility with them because we
promised them things that we and we did
them that's very important you know in
prison you need to if you commit to
something you have to deliver please
don't make false promises or commitments
if you cannot deliver okay yeah so my
other released peer leaders are now
being involved in community training
sessions in fact sionary was you know
one of the updates that you just gave me
was that they were just recently invited
to perform in this slum community on the
outskirts of Delhi about hiv/aids
prevention so she's super excited about
it Thank you Thank You sionary thank you
thank you ok so I'm going to quickly
tell you what worked for us partnerships
very important you cannot you cannot
work without partners there's only so
much that you can do on your own ok so
why not use exist people who are doing
work already an existing resources that
was one of the key strengths of our
program we involved not only just the
prison star we talked to the family
members we involve them in fact twice a
month the chairperson of the foundation
was a very senior police leader a very
senior police official in delhi in india
in fact meets with our peer leaders
family and talks to them and you know
listens to their grievances against the
law and you know which I and do whatever
we can we try and facilitate we have
home visits for our peer leaders have
not extended that to every member of the
group simply I mean every pure in the
training programs if you
we don't have the resources to do it and
we even partnered with other NGOs like
the voluntary HIV testing I don't have
the resources i just went and spoke to a
partner ng Electra to an NGO and they
said yeah we'll do it for free I was
like yay free that sounds good to me ok
and you know it's just the one thing
that we did do was to create parallel
structures and by that I mean you know
the government our government has the
political will to do stuff and they have
the resources they just lack
implementation skills so for example my
jail already had medical staff so why
should I involve people from outside to
come in when I can you know talk to them
and make them a part of this entire
project so we did not go about setting
up or you know holding special sessions
of testing or anything for every medical
concern we would direct them to the
existing center and you know you use the
help of the senior medical officer over
there you know how this helped us it
helped us break down all the walls that
we had there was like this very clear
divide you're not they didn't trust me
the prisoners did not trust me when I
walked in you know they said hmm we'll
see we'll see how this goes you know
I've they not to tell me you know the
way we thought that you're just going to
be one of those men who comes in does
her work and gets out I'm like okay
thank you so now like I said they're my
girls and my boys I'm a part of their
lives you know they've influenced my
life they've taught me so much they've
taught me patience they me how to
overcome certain obstacles and I had
quite a few of them and they taught me a
lot of other things that I don't want to
share it now with you so it helped me
build bridges basically you know with
with the officials you know I'm sure all
of you know that India is I would say
very corrupt nation but less corruption
so what was I don't have the resources I
can grease palms so what works for me is
you know making sure that we work with
the jail officials not against them okay
that is very important why should we
would you like it if I come and tell you
you're doing this wrong know that you
would say who the hell are you to tell
me you're doing this wrong so you know
there's a way to work around it you go
you know is okay thank you
so much you know you I understand where
you're coming from but you know how
about if we do it this way how about if
we do it this way no bugs you know just
a suggestion and it worked the next
important thing being flexible when I
walked into a when I went to India I had
the set timeline and a research protocol
it all went flying out of the window
might need the settlements which take
three months it took me just three
months to get permission getting into
prison my pure training was about to
take another three months it took me one
year to chain everyone so please be very
flexible in your approach and the most
important thing that worked for us my
personal mantra it's always possible
it's all there is no such thing that you
cannot do if you set your mind to doing
it you can do it there's no two ways
about it thank you ladies
you
the preceding program was brought to you
by Teachers College Columbia University
please visit us online at iTunes TC
columbia edu